I always assumed that the use of the
characters Rob is what 15 with his
father taken prisoner yeah I always
assumed the use of the prisoner use of
the characters might be true to medieval
times people got started earlier because
it lived much less longer romantically
correct and they said that you generally
raise the age of the TV show because it
just wasn't hard for us to look at a 15
year old leading an army and not be
skeptical about to mention the sexual
situations that many people get into the
the sexual secretary action was a huge
part of it
probably the the principal part of it I
mean it was the Daenerys question you
know in the book she's she's 13 years
old when we pick her up she's pregnant
at 14 and you know you cannot legally
portray that on TV that's not that's not
Leah and we also were filming in Britain
so British small days and in some ways
it's even more stringent than American
law even if we cast a 17 year old
actress who trained a 13 year old girl
that would have been a violation of
British obscenity laws so instead of a
17 year old playing a 13 year old we
have a 22 year old claim 17 year old but
if you have been aged up daenerys
because everything ties into what
happened you know during Robert's
rebellion and the sack of King's Landing
and the Battle of the Trident and you
have to age of all of the characters but
I think the question that you mention
there about yes believability is it's
another question although it's
frustrating because as you say it did
have an epidural history there were
plenty of young Lords who you know led
armies at 14 and 15 and won battles and
all that the whole concept of
adolescence as we have that in our
modern society is a modern construct you
know there was no such concept of being
a teenager in in the ancient world of
the medieval world they were
coming-of-age ceremonies and when you
came of age were of age and you were an
adult we still have you know remnants of
that of course the Jewish people have
the the
miss fun you know today I am a man they
13 year old service I believe and that's
believe was exactly my word today I am a
man so now I will drive in three volumes
shut up go right back to being this sort
of you know China then Catholicism where
I was raised
has a similar right D confirmation right
which one takes place at 13 wait you are
expected to confirm as an adult the vows
that were taken for you when you were
baptized by other people by your
references trial now you firm them as a
confirmation thing to clear your old
growing up at 13 so we still have the
rights we just don't believe in them
anymore we've created this whole
artificial thing of teenager gamma and I
don't know I suppose this decides with
moderate and very much manipulator of
what
well it's uh we did poking some younger
Mercury's but you know Natalie Dormer
was so fantastic that you know that we
decided to go with them and I again I I
love that casting choice she was in the
tutors if any of you watch that tutors
was uh I think first season had a few
problems with it and then it really
picked up steam and it was a great show
except for the lead if you disregard the
guy playing in eighth the wife or all
fantastic especially Natalie Dormer as
in Belen and she's she's amazing but of
course she is older than Cerberus which
is the reverse in the book so lorises is
a year older than Marjorie so it has
affected the character someone Arian are
you are there's a lot of fun
I could write a little novel about Aria
in Braavos she's just you know she's
just fun to to write about
well it seems good recurrent with both
of those characters so I think really
resonate for a lot of people who read
the books you're fascinated with people
who are perceived as Outsiders or you
know someone who's not you know you
don't say well you don't normally in the
course of life think wow a ten-year-old
girl is really going to kick everyone's
ass like that's not something that's
like the expected thing I did you not to
get psychoanalytical here at the end of
the panel but have you felt like an
outsider isn't is that something that
just kind of is a part of your makeup
sure
I suspect that's true of almost everyone
in the whole here science fiction
community one of the great things about
coming into fandom is you know there's
the sense that I certainly had I know a
lot of fan staff who I found my people
you know previously been in a lot of
situations in high school and college
and whatever were you were the odd one
the you know what used to be called
nerds or geeks or laughing or that was a
term of pride and something that people
self-identify as what it was that
pejorative used to put one down but I
would say like 90% of the characters in
ice and fire are misfits in one way or
another you know they are Jon Snow as a
bastard Tyrion is a dwarf Arya is the
tomboy doesn't fulfill her proper social
roles you know Danny is an exile who's
lost everything
you know sand it's fact and rejected by
his father and you know you go you've
gone on through the list Brianna's
another character who's you know
freakishly tall and manly and therefore
rejected as as not fulfilling her proper
roles and I just find those characters
fascinating to write about and how
people how people deal with that kind of
how do I find my place in society do I
try to conform to what I'm supposed to
be do I reject it do I carve out a new
place for myself and Tyrion probably the
one who thought about it most and he
gives Jon Snow the advice to hear about
you know no anymore except what you are
to never forget what you are visible not
just so we're clear you're pro
freakishly tall ladies well that's a
nice number
it's a prime mover so I thought the
visible and it's a historically a lucky
number
and it seemed to make a good number for
my thoughts I wanted to have a version
of the Catholic faith that you know
which has de the Trinity and so I looked
for another number I could spoiler codes
on with 507 instead it seemed to balance
out nicely you know allowed me to
include the stranger who was a kind of
the most interesting part of that
pantheon of seven it was really just one
God with seven s extra says the I was
told as a kid did them it was only one
God but he had three wait my sister when
I was growing up we would eat for peace
first and then her mashed potatoes and
then their meat and she would never
alternate them she and she didn't like
them to touch on the plate either so I
on the other hand would take my mashed
potatoes and and sort of make a volcano
a letter in the middle so it melted and
the peas on top of it and removed rolled
together and so I'm much more much much
more the characters together
they need them separately
[Music]
[Applause]